une élue en place est aux affaires
voilà selon marie louise fort elle-même
son principal avantage dans cette
élection municipale la mère de sens a dû
faire face et gérer la crise du
coronavirus forte de ses 40% du premier
tour elle compte plus que jamais sur la
fameuse prime au sortant
le bilan vous vous promenez c'est les
quais de l'yonne c'est partout donc ça
je pense que ça compte dans l'esprit des
gens je pense que la crise c'était un
petit plus mais rien n'est jamais gagné
et ce qui serait quand même intéressant
c'est effectivement si je dois gagner
c'est pas gagné a dit voit quoi
mon but c'est plutôt ça
la mère de sens est candidate et l'air
aura face à elle la liste de laurent -
n'ai croisé ici place de la république
cette liste soutenue par le ps est
arrivé en deuxième position avec près de
17% des voix mais laurent moinet ex
directeur de cabinet de l'ancien maire
daniel paris n'a pas su rassembler
davantage pas d'alliance avec les
écologistes qui partiront seuls de leur
côté et ce malgré le risque de laisser
un boulevard à marie louise fort ça
c'est une réflexion en mathématiques
nous on va résonner plutôt sur des sur
des projets et sur des alliances
possibles c'est à dire qu'à un moment
donné on ne peut pas s'entendre avec
avec des strings gauche en l'état qui
sont des extrémistes dogmatique et nous
on est plutôt sur un raisonnement projet
et à large rassemblement centre gauche
et centre droit véritable surprise du
premier tour avec plus de 11 % des voix
la liste écologiste est arrivée en
quatrième position
elle regroupe des verts donc mais aussi
des insoumis et des communistes
elle a refusé de fusionner et mathieu
bitoun la tête de liste l'assumé
totalement
on a déjà eu par le passé des listes de
large réunion des parties les plus à
gauche centre gauche on va dire de
l'échiquier politique à sens on a vu ce
que ça a donné avec l'explosion en vol
du mandat de monsieur paris
des gens qui sont partis dans tous les
sens je suis pas persuadé que ce soit
meilleur pour la ville que
va voir marie louise fort qui gagne et
qui fera son projet il est mauvais mais
voilà ça explosera sans doute pas en
voilà avec une manifestation de soutien
au policier devant le commissariat de
sens
julien odoul et ses colistiers ont
décidé d'occuper le terrain le candidat
est reine plaçait de grands espoirs dans
cette élection mais sa liste n'est
arrivé qu'en troisième position avec
près de 15% des voix
pour autant ils croient encore à la
victoire il ya plus troisième position
là on est tous à égalité on est qualifié
pour cette élection du 28 juin c'est une
élection à un tour à la proportionnelle
ça peut changer parce que nous électeurs
ne sont pas allés voter la dernière fois
nous avons énormément d'électeurs qui
sont restés chez eux pour des raisons
légitimes parce qu'ils avaient peur pour
leur santé
moi je leur dis que maintenant il faut
se bouger maintenant il faut aller aux
urnes et que maintenant ils peuvent tout
changer
avec 4 liste présente au second tour
marie louise fort à toutes les chances
de se succéder à elle même à la mairie
de sens la question est plutôt de savoir
si elle sera plébiscité ou non et
surtout si les sénonais participant en
nombre au scrutin